yeah as well in Swindon back in Swindon
for the launch of our local election
campaign it's so good to be here with
you these elections really really matter
and we've got to go out and we've got to
win them
because at the heart of these elections
is a really simple question do you think
do you believe that Britain deserves
better
deserves better than long lists at your
local hospital
better than crime soaring anti-social
Behavior going up yet neighborhood
policing going down
better than yet more tax rises in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
because if the answer to that is yes
Britain deserves better there's
something you can do about it which is
go out on May the 4th Thursday May the
4th and vote labor
[Applause]
we have to send a message a message to
this government
what they're delivering for our country
is not good enough it's nowhere near
good enough
seven million people on NHS waiting
lists crime going virtually unpunished
and yet more tax rises in the middle of
a cost of living crisis does anyone
seriously think that Britain can't do
better than this
across the country everywhere I go here
in Swindon communities have ambition
they won't change they just don't have a
government that matches their ambition
and they're not going to get it from
this prime minister
it's the one percent
one percent of Asylum claims from those
arriving or small boats actually process
one percent of the fraud that was lost
during covert actually recovered nor
percent of the windfall tax that could
have helped working people actually
collected
and as new tax policy
same as his old tax policy
a tax cut for the richest one percent
whilst working people pay the price
this has to change this has to stop
and I know that some people are saying
well I've heard this before nothing ever
changes we can't really do anything
and I understand after 13 years of Tory
failure that sentiment that sense that
things can't change
that's what we're up against the Tories
and they're narrowing of our ambition of
our communities
so we've got to go out there each and
every one of us and make the case for
change so that we're hungry for change
decline is not inevitable
the cost of living crisis is not
inevitable sticking plaster politics is
not inevitable there are choices to be
made
we would choose to put 13 000
neighborhood police on the beat keeping
us safe thousands more doctors and
nurses train so our NHS is fit for the
future a real cost of living plan that
will help people with their prices help
them to get through and raise their
living standards
there are choices on tax as well we need
to revive our high streets by cutting
our business rates and we need to be
clear about council tax
labor would freeze council tax next year
using using that windfall tax that
hasn't been collected Yes you heard it
right not a penny more on your council
tax not a penny more than the bill you
paid last year and that is a tax cut for
the 99 of working people
compared with the tax percentage
[Applause]
compared with the tax cut for the
richest one percent that we get under
the Tories so let's get out there let's
be campaigning all around the country
starting here in Swindon this morning
out there taking our message to every
doorster about what the choices are that
we would make in government
so there is a choice there's a
difference we can make that difference
that choice by voting labor on Thursday
the 4th of May and build a better
Swindon and build a better Britain thank
you all for everything that you're going
to do in this campaign thank you and
thank you
foreign
[Applause]